i've got good news and i've got bad news
the good news is that joe biden is
finally ending the covid restrictions
the bad news is he's only ending them
for illegal aliens who are trying to
break into our country
law-abiding american citizens still need
to muzzle up at least on public
transportation where the cdc has
reportedly decided to extend the federal
mass mandate
for just two more weeks
just two two more weeks where have i
heard that one before
at the same time joe biden is officially
ending the title 42 public health
authority first invoked by president
trump that allowed immigration officials
to turn away illegal aliens and send
them back to their native countries
relatively quickly compared to the rest
of our system
so
biden is apparently worried that
americans might spread the new
sub-variance of the variant of the virus
that even in its most virulent form
never posed much of a threat
at all to the vast majority of americans
but he's not worried that millions of
unvetted foreigners from countries with
much lower public health standards than
we have we'll spread the same virus to
each other and to us great news for
people who want to take advantage of our
country
bad news for our country's own citizens
in other words
more of the same two weeks after two
weeks after two years later here we are
again
nothing changing here to help me make
sense of this because you know we do not
merely want to
be pyromaniacs in a field of straw men
we want to hear out what the other side
has to say and here are the best
arguments for what what seems to us to
be absolutely absurd kind of policy so
we're very happy to be joined by jen
perlman who is an attorney an activist a
former congressional candidate in
florida's 23rd congressional district
and right now the force behind the
generational change podcast and i love
me a good pun jen thank you for coming
on the show
thank you for having me so
jen this is our first time meeting we
haven't really spoken before i don't
know where you stand on this issue
frankly i don't know where the majority
of democrats stand on this issue
but it seems to me
two years later two years
now more than two years after two weeks
to slow the spread
isn't the covid stuff over can't we move
on and take the mask off and go back in
public and just live live our lives
well i have um you're not gonna get
you're not gonna get that much of an
argument from me i'm i'm pretty
vehemently opposed to mandates in
general um
i think that
the policies for covid from the
beginning
have been based on two things fear and
profit and neither of those things are
reason and that's generally how i like
to go about policy making is through
reason and uh that's not how it's ever
been handled so i totally agree with you
do you think that that view because i
i've heard other left-wingers say this
though it seems to be a maybe a minority
view on the democrat side just knowing
the party do you think
that the majority of democrats are with
biden on this and keep locking down and
keep wearing masks or do you think
they're ready to move on uh okay so when
you say the majority of democrats okay
that's a very interesting thing because
technically i'm one i'm registered as
one i lived in i live in a closed
primary state so i have very i have no
option for myself but i don't agree with
them i don't support their policy i
don't like joe and i don't think the
majority of people do so when you say
democrats like yeah there's going to be
certain establishment right you know
blue or die people that are just going
to say yes to whatever he said but i
don't think most people support him i
think his poll numbers show that
i think you're right about that i mean
you know the the poll numbers are in the
doldrums and it's not just true abiding
it's true for the entire administration
kamala's down at 35 or something right
now buddha judge has been there around
the whole time he was the next one they
kind of wanted to make happen so then
good luck with that good luck yeah i
agree with you i don't think he's going
anywhere so then then what does that
mean for the party because i don't think
that your
anti-establishment anti-biden
perspective
is particularly fringe in the democrat
party if you look policy after policy
right now it would seem to me that the
majority or at least a huge number of
democrats really don't like what biden
is doing so so what what does that mean
for 2022 and 2024
oh i think it's very easy we're going to
get the dems are going to get their
asses handed to them this year and i am
actually and i've been saying this for a
very long time i truly believe your next
president is going to either be donald
trump or ron desantis
and and
the democrats are the only people that
don't seem to know this actually in
florida they're extremely delusional in
florida they're actually running a race
against desantis this year for governor
that they have zero chance of winning
and in my mind he's not even running
that he already won that he's running
for president already so the democrats
at least in florida are very behind the
eight ball i think they're living in a
fantasy land and again i'm referring to
the people on the inside the the
establishment democrats not just
everybody who's registered as a democrat
so is your issue with the party that uh
they they're not enough like desantis
you know we've got to go they've got to
go much further to the right or are you
hitting them from the left
oh i'm left of them for sure yeah i'm
left of them for sure uh but my issue
with all of it is the corruption um if
like i would support let me tell you i
will support and i and i will do and i
am doing that actually right now in
north carolina i will support a
non-corporate republican over a
corporate democrat
so for me it comes down to who do you
work for and who pays your salary and
the way i see it is they they're
supposed to work for us those are our
employees they're extremely
insubordinate um and as a result we
can't get policy that the majority of
people want so i don't support anybody
who's a corporate [ __ ] and that goes
for both sides of the aisle i remember a
lot of my friends in la some of whom
were pretty prominent left wingers
actually before 2016 they said if the
democrats nominate hillary she's going
to lose i won't vote for her my friends
won't vote for her
because she's this absolute corporate
establishment shill and and it she's she
won't offer us a choice she won't you
know it'll be a an echo rather than a
choice to parrot the language of the
right 50 years ago so
what would your advice be right now
you're in the room you've got all those
crooked democrat establishment types
there who are just trying to run the
same old playbook what would you tell
them to do to have a chance against a
trump against a desantis against whoever
the nominee is going to be right now the
movement is populism okay it's populism
on the left it's populism on the right
and i said this in 16. i said to people
i said if you don't support bernie
you're getting trump that's it hillary
has no chance of winning um i knew that
then i i understand it because she's
horrible uh there's nothing that would
have made me vote for her and so you
know they are not responding to what
people want and particularly what labor
needs
if you're not see labor is the unifying
force amongst us if you go to a labor
rally for example you're going to meet
reds and blues there and they're not
going to be sitting there and arguing
about wedge issues they're going to be
sitting there and be fighting for a
living wage at their where they work and
those are things that unify all of us
the the democrats need to get behind um
economic policy that will help people
and stop worrying about wedge issues
that are just there to make them look
like they have some sort of like moral
high ground they're extremely
sanctimonious they don't offer any real
substance of strategy or anything that
will help regular people get themselves
out of the mess that we're in right now
you know you're focusing on something
that's so insightful which is look i'm a
culture warrior i think some of the
cultural issues are important especially
now in education i think they drive
voters but i think you're right on this
labor point historically speaking the
party that can speak to american workers
and can talk that language and offer
them something very often does well
because you get red and you get blue and
which the party of pittsburgh tends to
do a little bit better than the party of
paris and right now democrats have made
themselves the party of paris i've got
to let you go i'm up against a break jen
where can people find you
i am at generational change on youtube
spotify and on itunes and our website is
generationalchange.com that's
generational with a j
and i'm at gen fl 23 on twitter i love
that but next time you come back by that
time i hope i will have a cool pun for
my podcast title we'll need a little bit
of time to work on it maybe you can
offer some suggestions hey if i come up
with something good i'll give it to you
i don't even see you
so uh yeah but if i think of something
really good i'll offer it to you please
do email it over to me i appreciate it
jen jen pelman thank you so much for
coming on
you know i have to tell you i expected
more
support for joe biden's policies from
jen from a democrat candidate but when
you look at the poll numbers maybe i
shouldn't have actually because
as she said she said look i'm not a
republican i don't support republicans
but by a lot of democrats don't support
what biden is doing right now the poll
numbers reflect that i think the white
house knows it frankly i think that's
why they're pushing the kovitz stuff
glad you like that clip now hold up
ring the bell subscribe
get those notifications get past the big
tech sensors we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you